it's a dark time for the global economy
from all over the world delegates and
representatives are in Washington to be
told what many already know economically
things are bad and they're going to get
worse the global economy continues to
face steep challenges shaped by three
powerful forces
the Russian invasion of Ukraine
the cost of living crisis caused by
persistent and broadening inflation
pressures
and the slowdown in China inflation is
biting economies around the world making
it harder for ordinary people to do
ordinary things like feed their families
or warm their homes the IMF says the
reasons are many and are complicated but
strict covert lockdowns in China has hit
growth there and impacted the global
supply chain there are several climate
emergencies and there's Russia's war in
Ukraine which has hit Food Supplies and
caused an energy crisis this winter in
Europe is described by the IMF as
challenging but warns next winter will
be worse when it comes to the cost of
living crisis the way to go is to
provide targeted support to the most
vulnerable households and firms rather
than a very general support which would
just make things even more difficult
it's not hard to find economic trouble
Sports Lebanon with political upheaval
and the banking sector crisis Sri Lanka
with double-digit economic slump and
huge debts or Pakistan more massive
floods have wreaked havoc this is the
first in-person gathering for the
international monetary Fund in three
years but facing the biggest coming
together of Economic Security and
climate challenges since the second
world war there's an acceptance that
this can't be business as usual Alan
Fisher Al Jazeera at the IMF annual
meeting in Washington